what's going on guys this is rob and we
are here with the trailer for spider-man
no way home i've never seen so much hype
surrounding me we'll talk about that
here in a minute let's let's let's do
the thing do the damn thing the thing
you guys all want to see
let's check out this trailer
just the opening two seconds
ever since i got bit by that
spider i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker's spiderman it is a screwed up
spell
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
[Music]
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so
scooby doo this crap you know all this
is kind of your mess i know a couple of
magic words myself starting with the
word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
look there has to be another winch there
isn't
there a danger to our universe
[Music]
you're not gonna take this away from me
oh my god
you're struggling
to have
everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
oh my god
electro
looks amazing are they going to gwin
stacy mj are they going to grind stacy
her ass oh my god dude that would be
nuts
and that would change everything okay so
i bet the reason why they're fighting is
because of the fact that peter parker
wants to save them and doctor trains
like no they have to die like they're
supposed to die and peter's like no we
can't kill them like we have to let them
live if they're here they can live in
this universe we can fix them we can
redeem them all that kind of stuff right
and doctrine is like no like you're
messing with a multiverse if you do that
um
wow
there's that okay you know what we're
gonna do uh this is a reaction video
we need to go through the trailer right
we need to go through the trailer and we
need to we need to figure all this stuff
out so we will do that tomorrow tomorrow
we're going to go through all the
through like the whole trailer
everything you missed all the theories
and everything let me tell you guys
right now for like the next while
it's just theory vision right it's just
it's it's theory vision here on get
closer explain right or our geek
theories is all it's gonna be we should
call it theory vision we should give it
a name we should call it theory vision
that's what it should be called right
like one division theory vision
this it just it just seems cool anyway
we're gonna do that uh yeah let me
bounce off here we got a lot of work to
do and i will catch you all later peace